in this video i want to introduce you to
the idea of a list
of a list and python it's one of the
most powerful data structures in python
and it really is just a sequence of a
bunch of other stuff so a list in python
would look something like this so this
would be a list of integers
maybe 1
negative 7 0
and 10
and we could have some variable refer to
it so that we can we can refer back to
it later on in a program so maybe we say
a
is equal to all of this and so if we run
this in the interpreter or if we run
this in a program now we can refer to
the elements of a and you do that by so
let's say i have a
let me write it the same pink color
you do that by referring to the index of
the element inside of the list so if i
say
a and then in brackets i put a 0 here
this says the 0th element in a
0th element and the general convention
in python and this is true in most
programming languages is what some
people would consider the first item in
an array or inside of a list you would
call it the zeroth item or the index of
this item right here is zero so if you
were to type this into interpreter or if
you type this in a program it would
evaluate as this item right over here it
would be this item right over there and
let's let me do another example if i
were to say a of i should say a of if i
were to say the
second element in the second element in
a this would be
zeroth element first element second
element it would be this zero
right over there so that's how you refer
to elements in lists and you can maybe
already imagine doing interesting things
with that but what's really cool with
lists is that they don't all have to be
the same data type they could be all
integers or all floats or all strings
but you could mix it up so you could
you could actually you could take a
right over here and you could redefine
one of the elements so you could say
you could say a
you could say let's reset i'll do that
same pink color let's reset the
the
i don't know let's say the the fourth
element let's reset the fourth element
in a to be equal to
to be equal to
this text
so literally this text
literally this text
and so if you did that if you set the
fourth element of a to be this text and
then you were in your program say print
print a
then a would look like this
the zeroth element wouldn't change still
be a one this first element would still
be a negative seven that's the so this
is zero first this this the two indexed
element would be still be a zero this
would be the third so this is zeroth
index first second third fourth we
replaced the fourth element so the
fourth element will now be this text
it would now be
this
will now be this text and in a second
we're actually going to try it out with
the python interpreter
and then the last element will still be
the last element will still be 10. and
this will be completely valid to do in
python you can mix data types like this
in fact you could even if you after
after you did this you could even say
that
a
let's redefine the zeroth element of a
to be another list to be the list
negative one negative two and if you did
this then this zero element over here
will in the list the zeroth element will
now refer to this thing so the list will
now look like this
so the first element or the zeroth
element i should say will now be this
thing negative one negative two and then
you'd have your negative seven 0
this text
and then you'll have your 10 just like
that so when you define it this way it
literally replaces or the 0th will now
refer to this data structure right over
here and you can maybe already imagine
useful ways to use this in programs if
you can't don't worry about it we'll see
useful ways
now there's one thing that i want to
make very clear here
is that when i let's say that i have let
me define some new let's say i have
some list that i have the variable b
referred to and let's say i make this
list
7 13
15. so that's my list and let's say that
i the next line in my program or maybe
using the python interpreter i say that
c
is equal to b
and sometimes you might be tempted to do
this as like look i want a copy of b and
what i want to make clear is at this
point c and b are actually pointing at
the same thing they're referring to the
same thing so if you wanted to think
about what's happening there's some
entity
in memory that looks like this 7 13 15.
and when you execute this
well when you execute this first line
over here that says that look b is going
to definitely refer to that
if the variable b
refers to this entity and when you say c
is equal to b this is actually saying
that c is going to refer to the same
thing that b is referring to
so c
is also going to refer to this exact
same thing c is not a copy of it we
didn't make a copy of it and make c
refer to that and what's relevant here
is if we now change c we're also going
to change or if we change what c is
referring to we'll also change what b is
referring to and i'll show you that in a
second with the interpreter but let me
show you what i'm talking about
so at this point i say that c
if i the next line i say that c
the 0th element in c needs to be equal
to 1. and if i were to tell you then
print c
if i were to then print c you would get
you would get
1 13 and 15.
but if you were to if you were to say
print b you would also get 1 13 and 15.
and that's because this call right over
here or this this statement right over
here
it changes what the zeroth element in
this list refers to so it won't refer to
a seven anymore it'll refer to a one so
now if you say
now if you say b of zero this will be
equal to one and not seven so you might
say well sell okay i understand that so
if i set a variable equal to another
variable that refers to a list they're
actually referring to the same list and
if i change one of the items in the list
that this is referring to it's actually
changing what this is referring to so
how could i copy lists how could i
actually copy it and there you use you
use the the notion that you can actually
and i'll i'll write it right over here
if you actually wanted to copy things
you would do this
you would write c
is equal to b
and this might look a little funny for
you but you put this colon sign over
here and what this does is it tells you
copy everything in b from the beginning
of b all the way to the end of the b so
you could write you could write you
could write c is equal to
b and then you could say 0
0 all the way to
up to but not including up to but not
including the second element so this
right over here this would create a new
this would create a new uh
list that is the zeroth and only the
first element it won't include the
second element so in this case
what you do so this one right over here
would create a new list that looks like
this
that creates that looks like well if if
we if we assume we haven't changed b yet
if we assume that this was our
definition of b it'll create a new list
that looks like this
and c will now refer to this new list
so c c will now refer to this new list
so it created a copy of the first two
elements the zeroth element and the
first not the second element you would
have to put three here if you wanted the
second element so up to but not
including the second element if you
wanted all of the elements to copy you
would do this so this is implicitly
saying from the beginning all the way to
the end so it would create it would
create a separate list it would look
create a separate list that looks just
like b
but it's a separate one and then c could
refer to that and now if you change c if
now if you change c you won't change b
so enough of just talking about it let's
actually play with it on our let's play
with it on our interpreter because this
is the fun stuff right over here
so let's say that we have
let's say that
let me get rid of some of this text that
i have there so you don't get confused
so let's say i define some list a is
equal to
let me write it this way 1 2
negative 7
11. so i've defined a and we can even
verify that print a you can see it right
there we can change one of the elements
in a we could say let's change
the first element and remember when we
say when we have an index one we're not
talking about this one here this is the
zeroth element so we're changing this
one right over here
so let's change that let's just for fun
let's change that to a string
so
sals
sal's string
and now let's see what a looks like
print a so notice it took this this is
the index one this is the the first one
zeroth element first element it changed
the first element to cell string and we
see it right there
now let's do something interesting let's
set b equal to a and let's print
let's print b let's print b so it looks
just like a and let me do something else
let me let c equal to
a
a and then do what i talked about so let
me make c equal to a copy of a
so let's print c print c
so b and c look the same but they're two
different things c is a copy of a or c
is a copy of the thing that a is
referring to b is the thing that a is
referring to and to see that
let's change the first element of both b
and c
so if you change the first element of b
so b of z the zeroth element in b let's
just make that and let's make it equal
to let's make it equal to zero
let's make it equal to zero so now if we
print b
you see the first element is zero and
what you'll also see is if you print a
the first element will be zero now
because they were referring to the same
thing so it said whatever b is referring
to make its the very zeroth element make
that equal to zero well a was referring
to the same thing so it also became zero
but c is referring to a copy so c should
not have changed
c did not change the zeroth element here
did not change a bit so i'll leave you
there lists are super powerful there's a
ton of functions you can do with lists
in fact i'll expose you to a few right
here so if that is a you can add
elements to a so you could say a
dot append and you can add something to
the end of a so you could add ah
you know new element
new element and if you do that it should
end it to it should add it to the end of
a so let's look at a it added that
element well b is referring to the same
thing so let's see what b looks like it
has a new element c is referring to a
copy of the old a so let's see what that
looks like didn't add it there because
it didn't add it to the copy that added
only to what a was referring to which is
the same thing that b is referred to and
there's a ton of useful functions and
we'll explore them as we do more and
more pro programs uh more more example
problems programs but there's a bunch of
useful functions or methods that lists
have to be able to manipulate them and
change them in different ways